[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ce dossier sensible
je vais partager mon interprétation on
nous parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuel devenir riche en
matières premières il va connaître une
croissance économique moyenne de 7% par
an pour les 30 prochaines années soit un
développement équivalent à celui de la
chine durant la période précédente
d'un autre côté les problèmes de
gouvernance étatique et les confits tous
ordres qui s'y succèdent montrent que
tout n'y est pas simple enfin la poussée
migratoire africaine et les difficultés
d'intégration qui en résultent inquiète
les pays du nord de la méditerranée
l'afrique est temps compliqués en parler
difficile quand on ne fait pas l'effort
de rentrer dans sa réalité
pour la comprendre dans sa diversité et
ses non dits
l'histoire des relations entre l'europe
du sud et l'afrique montre que nous
avons une communauté de destin nos
intérêts sont liés et nous avons tout
intérêt à contribuer sous une forme ou
sous une autre au développement
économique africain car c'est un marché
pour nous comme nous sommes a marché
pour eux une de nos erreurs fut de ne
pas le comprendre et l'intégrer lors de
la création de l'union européenne il est
donc intéressante analyse et loin de
toute idéologie la situation actuelle
qui peut aussi bien nous pénaliser que
contribuer positivement à notre
évolution future
mais tout d'abord arrêtons de rêver
l'afrique de demain ne sera jamais la
chine d'aujourd'hui celle ci ayant
interdit d'avoir plus d'un enfant par
famille pendant plus de 30 ans a pu
consacrer tous les moyens issus son
développement à sa croissance en afrique
avec un taux moyen de fécondité de 3,6
enfants par famille qui monte même à 4,8
dans la partie subsaharienne
la plus grande partie du produit de la
croissance sera consacrée à nourrir ses
habitants au détriment du reste pour la
survie de sa population qui est la plus
déshéritée du monde
on était à 41% de ses occupants vivant
en 2013 dans l'extrême pauvreté
elle doit développer en priorité son
agriculture en l'adaptant à l'évolution
climatique et la production de produits
de première nécessité pour assurer son
avenir
elle doit également investir dans des
industries de première et deuxième
transformation dans les infrastructures
aujourd'hui en dehors de l'afrique du
sud ainsi que d'une partie du maghreb et
de l'afrique de l'est
l'industrie africaine est encore trop
faible pour pouvoir accompagner le
développement en cours
certes l'agencé française de
développement le fmi la banque africaine
de développement la banque européenne
d'investissement les banques marocaine
ou turque et bien d'autres mais surtout
les chinois proposé financement qui sont
rarement
font perdre ils permettent la
réalisation de projets structurels mais
la corruption endémique en détourne
selon l'onu
75 milliards de dollars vers les
dirigeants et les ethnies ou tribus au
pouvoir il est vrai que la culture
africaine traditionnelle oblige celui
qui détient le pouvoir ou l'argent d'en
faire bénéficier l'ensemble des membres
de sa tribu ou de son environnement
ce système de redistribution que d'une
variante archaïque de notre système
français d'imposition fiscale et de
sécurité sociale a toujours été pratiqué
son dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
on le constate à travers l' affaire des
biens mal acquis qui vise directement
les présidents à leurs familles au gabon
au congo brazzaville et en guinée
équatoriale et soyons clair ils ne sont
que la partie émergée d'un iceberg
africains beaucoup plus vastes comme
l'avait si bien démontré le regretté
pierre péan
indiscutablement les pays occidentaux
ont favorisé cette dérive en
encourageant le maintien au pouvoir de
politiciens de plus en plus âgés pour
assurer la stabilité des pays et des
sous régions
savez vous que ces vieux sages ont en
moyenne dix ans de plus que les
dirigeants européens sont ils capables
de comprendre et gérer une population
donc 40% à moins de quinze ans et qui va
doubler en une génération
l'ancien président de elf loïk le floch
prigent qui est indiscutablement un des
meilleurs connaisseurs de l'afrique
rappelé récemment que contrairement aux
recommandations de la cedeao
les français n'ont rien dit lors de la
modification de la constitution du congo
brazzaville ou du tchad pour permettre
une réélection de leur président en
place
ils ont ainsi laissé ouvrir une brèche
dans laquelle se sont engouffrés le
burundi la guinée la côte d'ivoire et
bien d'autres à dire vrai antho dehors
de quelques pays comme le ghana ou le
sénégal
il faut du courage ou de l'inconscience
pour être opposant dans ces élections
aux résultats officiels souvent
discutables regard des règles
internationales
trop souvent ceux qui veulent agir sont
marginalisés par ceux qui ont le pouvoir
à craignent de le perdre
regardez en afrique francophone comment
sont traités les opposants emprisonnés
comme au congo brazzaville à faire du
général mokoko assassiné comme au rwanda
membres de l'état major du parti de
victoire ingabire obligé de se cacher
comme au togo cas de l'ancien premier
ministre agbéyomé kodjo de s'exiler
comme au tchad les familles proches du
chef toum ou rayés des listes de
candidature à la présidence en côte
d'ivoire comme guillaume soro en dépit
des injonctions de la cour africaine des
droits de l'homme
il est donc évident qu'en dépit des
vertueuse indignation de certains
philosophes et de la susciter de
certains politiques face à des
situations dont nous sommes trop souvent
à l'origine ou complice
on ne peut mettre sur le même plan
l'afrique avec sa majorité démocrate
sûrs avec l'europe
les anciennes puissances coloniales ont
toujours que le développement et le
progrès des bouchers forcément sur le
libéralisme et la démocratie à
l'européenne l'état de droit
proposant sur les usages une copie de
leur code civil et sur l'individu au
coeur du système n'avait pourtant rien
de commun avec l'afrique où
l'organisation et communautaire et le
droit de tradition coutumière elles ont
eu la prétention de croire que les
valeurs qu'elle défend des est imposé
par la force dans leur conquête était
universel alors qu'elle était intimement
liée à leur culture leur histoire et
leurs systèmes de pensée après la
décolonisation elles ont imaginé le
droit d'ingérence qui permet d'envahir
un pays au nom de valeurs occidentales
qui ne sont pas les siennes
d'autant qu'il n'a pas droit à la parole
on devrait pourtant se questionner sur
la justesse de notre approche
quand on voit les pays africains se
sentir plus proche de la démocratie
indienne du modèle chinois ou des
théocraties arabe pour mesurer l'écart
de compréhension entre nos élites et les
populations locales
il suffit d'écouter les commentaires de
nos amis africains sur la cour pénale
internationale de la haye une justice de
blancs pour juger les africains qui a
gardé dix ans prison en europe
l'ex président ivoirien laurent gbagbo
avant de se résoudre à le libérer
faute de preuves ce qui entre
parenthèses interpelle sur ce qu'on nous
avait raconté lors de son renversement
avec l'aide des forces spéciales
françaises
heureusement l'afrique commence à
prendre conscience de sa dimension
globale et de ce qu'elle représente au
niveau mondial selon les chiffres
fournis par le conseiller d'état antoine
pouliot tu rends experts de la
diplomatie économique dans une
conférence du 29 septembre à sinopia le
produit intérieur brut total des 54 pays
africains est équivalent à celui de la
france ce n'est pas rien mais elle reste
une mosaïque que l'on continue
traditionnellement et par facilité à
segmenter entre le maghreb l'afrique
francophone
l'anglophone et la luz ophone les
problèmes se concentrant principalement
dans la zone sahélienne et succès y en
réalité l'afrique est un ensemble de
pays très différents au niveau des
richesses de la population et du taux de
croissance qui ont leur existence propre
en dehors des blocs de l'ancien
colonisation regardez par exemple
l'afrique du sud où le revenu moyen
annuel par habitant est de 5400 80
dollars c'est à dire la moitié de celui
du portugal
comparer le au maroc avec ses 4000 85
dollars par habitant et au niger avec
ses 410 dollars soit dix fois moins et 7
enfants par famille on ne peut comparer
des grands payer pétroliers comme le
nigeria et l'angola avec un pays riche
mais minée par les problèmes internes
comme par exemple mozambique
on ne peut associer deux pays bien gérés
comme l'ethiopie qui entend croissance
rapide et la mauritanie qui reste
structurellement pauvres on ne vit pas
de la même manière en zone sahélienne au
niger ou au soudan et au zimbabwe cet
ancien rhodésie que les anciens de la
françafrique
les britanniques appelée la petite
suisse de surcroît
nombreuses sont les zones de conflit où
les cibles des compagnies minières
internationales
s'ajoutent aux oppositions ethniques
traditionnels et aux intérêts de pays
voisins comme on l'a vu au liberia et au
burkina faso pour le diamant est encore
aujourd'hui en ituri pour l'heure et le
coltane entre la république démocratique
du congo et l'ouganda
face à la croissance démographique il
faut nourrir est formé une jeunesse qui
veut légitimement évolué avec comme
référence ce qu'elle voit dans les
séries télévisées et ce qu'elle apprend
sur l'état du monde par internet et par
les réseaux sociaux n'oublions pas que
l'afrique était en retard sur les
infrastructures de communication est à
la pointe de l'utilisation du numérique
plus de 50 % de ses habitants de
téléphones portables et une très grande
partie de leurs propriétaires règlent
leurs factures et paie avec leurs
appareils
alors qu'ici nous continuons utiliser
nos cartes de crédit face aux
différences d'environnement économique
et climatique
la jeunesse est en quête de vie
meilleure elle veut accélérer
l'évolution est plus favorisés vont
faire des études dans les universités
françaises américaines russes ou
chinoises et reviennent au pays quand
ils en ont l'opportunité et plus
défavorisés migrent légitimant des pays
pauvres vers les pays riches du
continent en y créant beaucoup de
problèmes en particulier en périphérie
urbaine comme le disait le roi du maroc
hassan ii et son fils mohamed 6 a mis en
pratique si vous ne voulez pas de big
rend chez vous construisez des
industries de main d'oeuvre dans nos
pays
il y a donc en permanence des mouvements
de population qui désertifie les
territoires les plus démunis et
transforme l'afrique en un continent
disparates allant des pays riches aux
zones de non droit
obsédé par les chiffres bruts on oublie
que seulement 10% des migrants viennent
vers l'europe pour atteindre ce faux
eldorado ces hommes et ces femmes
prennent d'énormes risques tout au long
du trajet car il traverse des zones du
trafic en tout genre ou de guerre dans
laquelle ils sont exploités par des
trafiquants les mafias locales des
groupes terroristes et enfin des
transbordeurs tous leur font payer des
droits de passage élevé ou en nature par
le travail forcé ou une exploitation
physiques ou sexuelles même s'ils ne
sont qu'une petite minorité
les migrants vers l'europe continueront
c'est pourquoi l'avenir implique de
dépasser les dogmes généreux d1 et les
refus protectionnistes des autres qui
sont totalement inadapté aux réalités
des deux côtés de la méditerranée
il va falloir trouver avaient tous les
pays concernés
une formule efficace permettant
d'intégrer ce qu'il souhaite vraiment
mais que nous avons la capacité
d'accueillir socialement loin du
communautarisme des britanniques
la réponse chez nous place par
l'intégration en afrique
il faut savoir que les routes de
migration sont les mêmes que celles des
trafics d'armes de cigarettes de
produits pharmaceutiques ou de drogue
les organisations mafieuses du monde
entier ont compris l'intérêt de ces pays
très pauvre et sans population pour en
faire des sanctuaires où elles peuvent
régner en maître en achetant les
consciences c'est ainsi que la
guinée-bissau est considéré par beaucoup
comme un arc aux états et que sans cette
clé on ne peut comprendre ce qui vient
de se passer au mali avec le coup d'état
contre le président et bk notez qu'il en
est de même pour la piraterie qui
apparaît avoir été pratiquée par les
pêcheurs somaliens et érythréens
cornaqué par des organisations
internationales mafieuses dans l'océan
indien un et malte en plus concentrée
sur le golfe de guinée
de l'autre côté de l'afrique
au delà des conflits éthiques millénaire
qui explique beaucoup des tensions
actuelles comme l'analyse si bien
bernard lugan dans ses nombreux livres
sur l'afrique nous sommes en train de
vivre dans la bande sahélienne et
subsahélienne une montée de l'islamisme
radical qui d'aqmi à boko haram amené la
france à s'engager dans l'opération
serval puis barkan au niveau régional
serval dans sa destruction groupe
djihadiste au mali fut un véritable
succès mais c'est une zone où les
trafics en tout genre permettent depuis
fort longtemps à la population de
survivre comme l'expliqué guillaume
sotomayor dans le numéro 117 de la revue
recherches internationales que tous ceux
qui s'intéressent à l'afrique sahélienne
devraient lire pour comprendre la
réalité du terrain d'aujourd'hui on
léger dans par leurs opérations
les français sont devenus très
impopulaire barkan qui veut contrôler
une zone immense avec des moyens
efficaces mais extrêmement réduits
risque de devenir un conflit sans fin et
surtout sans réelle victoire
indiscutablement sous la pression
algérienne repoussant ces jihadistes
vers le sud avec l'aide financière
alimentaire des pays du golfe aux
populations locales
le matériel militaire récupérés dans les
arsenaux de kadhafi et l'aide actuelle
de la turquie via la libye
l'islamisme progresse bien au delà de la
zone des combats mais il ne faut pas
oublier qu'au départ l'afrique était et
reste fondamentalement animiste l'islam
arrivé du nord et de l'est avec les
marchands est devenue majoritairement un
islam soufi qui n'a rien à voir avec la
radicalité et la charia wahhabite et
puis la colonisation a mis le
christianisme qui est devenu majoritaire
aujourd'hui deux groupes essaient de
prendre le leadership et salafistes
islamique au nord
et les évangélistes protestants au
centre et au sud
à l'évidence au delà d'une guerre que
l'on ne peut gagner
la solution au nord passe par
l'amélioration des conditions de vie de
populations très peu et ceci implique un
effort important que les pays concernés
n'ont pas les moyens de faire seul et
pour le mali n'ont pas jusqu'ici
l'intention
il est évident que le continent africain
nous réserve encore des surprises
c'est une zone riche en matières
premières avec une population jeune qui
veut travailler pour produire et faire
de la transformation en grains de la
richesse loin des processus de
repentance qui ne rime à rien car
l'histoire ne se refait pas la vérité
finit toujours par sortir comme on peut
le voir par exemple avec le livre de
judy rêveur sur le rwanda
et cette vérité les rarement manichéenne
oubliant le passé pour construire un
avenir commun
nous avons tout intérêt à tisser
conjointement des liens économiques et
des changes avec les pays africains qui
le veulent
en les accompagnant dans leur évolution
et leur recherche de solutions
spécifiques nouvelle pour y arriver il
faut sortir des schémas simplistes et
univoque délivrés par des médias et des
réseaux sociaux manipulés par des
groupes de pression aux intérêts
économiques ou politiques variées du
racisme à rebours à l'anticolonialisme
primaire en passant par la réécriture de
l'histoire
leur caractéristique commune et le
dénigrement de l'action passée présente
et future de notre pays en afrique
les chinois ont annoncé lors d'un
colloque à abidjan les 8 et 9 octobre
qu'ils allaient ouvrir 80 de voix des
changes avec 48 pays africains pour
développer les liens économiques
on aurait donc tout intérêt à s'inclure
al nouvelle alliance prôné par jean
claude juncker l'ancien président de la
commission européenne et président
d'honneur de la fondation afrique
méditerranée europe cher elisabeth
guigou pour établir des ponts dans la
durée par des accords entre nos
continents dans cette terre des
possibles s'esquisse les figures du
monde à venir
comme le décrit magistralement le
professeur marocain soufiane frimousse
dans son livre afrique positive imm'pact
il faut changer notre logiciel et a été
dénigré le faire à l'africaine on aux
croyants co management à l'anglo-saxonne
de nombreux exemples montrent que
l'afrique est capable de concilier
tradition et modernité dans une
évolution managériale spécifique dans
laquelle la pratique de l'intelligence
sociétal intègre la culture ainsi que le
respect des croyances et des usages de
la population pour faire face à ses
besoins de développement
l'afrique doit se réinventer et à
l'année moyens de le faire au lieu de
tout perdre lui donnant des leçons
inadapté à la réalité
nous devons impérativement y contribuer
en tant que partenaire en tant qu'amie
pour construire un futur commun
à bientôt
[Musique]